en este vídeo quiero hablarles acerca de
la tercera forma de ver a las líneas
rectas pero antes de visualizar esta
tercera forma de ver a las líneas rectas
me gustaría repasar lo que ya hemos
visto acerca de cuáles son las formas en
las cuales podemos escribir a una línea
recta habíamos visto por ejemplo la
forma pendiente ordenada el origen que
era y es igual a mx más b que era algo
parecido a esto justo en el vídeo pasado
hablamos una nueva forma de ver a la
línea recta que era la forma punto
pendiente que decía que menos de uno es
igual a m por x menos x 110 menos de 1
es igual a m por x menos x 1 y por
ejemplo tenemos esta ecuación aquí abajo
que dice menos 7 10 menos de 1 es igual
a menos cinco en menos 5 sigue la
pendiente que multiplica a x menos 12 x
menos x 1 pues en este vídeo quiero ver
una tercera forma de ver a las líneas
rectas y esta vez voy a hablar de la
forma estándar de ver a una línea recta
y cuando hablo de la forma estándar de
ver a una línea recta estoy pensando en
la siguiente forma
a x más bella es igual a c y al final lo
primero que sí quiero decirte que es muy
importante es que estamos hablando de la
misma línea recta es decir podemos pasar
de una forma a otra podemos pasar por
ejemplo de esta forma a esta forma o de
esta forma de esta forma o regresarnos o
como tú quieras al final son tres formas
distintas de ver a la misma línea recta
así que en este caso tengo aquí tres
ejercicios tres rectas que me gustaría
pasar en la forma estándar y la primera
dice que es igual a 3x menos 8 vamos a
estrenar nuestra forma estándar de ver a
la línea recta que es x más bella iguala
cm así que déjame escribir esta ecuación
otra vez aquí abajo james es igual a 3x
menos 8 y aquí tengo mi función a mi
línea recta y bueno lo más fácil y lo
que se me ocurre es restar 3x de ambos
lados de la ecuación y me queda menos 3x
y del otro lado menos 3x y ahora sí voy
a restar y hacer las respectivas
operaciones menos 3x aquí no se opera
con nada entonces me quedan menos 3 x
más yen
más de color verde esto es igual y menos
3 x 3 de aquí se cancelan 3 x menos 3 x
se van y solamente me queda menos 8 y
qué creés ya está en su forma estándar
ya lo tenemos la forma x más bella es
igual a c donde vale menos 3 b vale 1 y
se vale menos 8 y date cuenta que
empezamos con una recta que estaba en su
forma pendiente ordenado el origen que
por cierto para mí esta es mi forma
favorita de ver a una línea recta porque
en esta forma yo puedo ver claramente
cuál es la intersección con el eje de
las 10 y además puedo ver la pendiente
mientras que la forma estándar no es tan
fácil ver la pendiente pero bueno aquí
tenemos un segundo ejercicio donde la
pendiente vale menos 5 y como pasamos a
la forma estándar lo que hay que hacer y
lo que se me ocurre primero es
distribuir este menos 5 y multiplicarlo
tanto por x como x menos 12 y que me va
a quedar pues no quedaría menos 7 es
igual a menos 5 por x es menos 5x y
después menos 5 por menos 12 menos por
menos me da más y 5 por 12 es 60 y bueno
después voy a sumar 7 damos
la ecuación lo que estoy haciendo es
pasar este menos 7 del otro lado de la
ecuación para que se puedan significar
con este 60 y que me quedaría más 77 de
este lado izquierdo me va a quedar
solamente james menos 77 se van y
entonces me queda james es igual a quien
déjame cambiar de color y es igual a
menos 5 por x menos 5x y 60 más 7 es lo
mismo que 67 más 67 y bueno si yo lo que
busco es la forma estándar de mi recta
aquí lo que tengo que hacer es sumar 5x
de los dos lados de la ecuación para que
yo pueda pasar este menos 5 x del lado
izquierdo de mi ecuación y así no va a
quedar la forma a x más bella igual
hacen y que me queda más 5 x es igual
estos dos se cancelan y solamente me
queda 67 y ya están aquí ya lo tengo de
la forma estándar tal vez tengo a los
términos un poco desordenados pero esto
es exactamente lo mismo que ver 5x más
igual a 67 donde valdría 5 donde
valdría 1 y en este caso se va a valer
67 y bueno aquí tengo algo así como
mixto no no tengo ni de la forma punto
pendiente ni de la forma pendiente orden
al origen tengo algo raro y lo quiero
pasar a la forma estándar así que lo
primero que voy a hacer va a ser
exactamente lo mismo que hice en el
ejercicio pasado voy a distribuir este 4
y me queda 3 yemas 5 es igual a 4 por
equis que es 4x y después 4 x menos 9
que es menos 36 paso seguido voy a sumar
bueno de hecho voy a restar 5 de ambos
lados de la ecuación con la idea de que
este 5 se pase del otro lado de la
ecuación y se puedan simplificar con
este menos 36 así que menos 5 menos 5
esté menos 5 + 5 se van y solamente me
queda 3 james del lado izquierdo y del
lado derecho me queda 4x y después menos
36 menos 5 lo cual me da menos 41 menos
41 y después voy a pasar este 4x del
otro lado de la ecuación con signo
contrario y para esto lo que voy a hacer
es restar 4x de ambos lados de la
ecuación
- 4x de este lado le voy a poner menos
4x y entonces me queda menos 4 x mas 3
menos 4 x + 3 días del lado izquierdo de
la ecuación déjame cambiar de color
menos 4 x + 3 james y del lado derecho
me va a quedar este y este se van y me
queda solamente menos 41 y ya lo tenemos
aquí otra vez ya lo tenemos en su forma
estándar de nuevo lo tenemos de la forma
x más bellas y wallace m y ahora vamos a
través qué pasa si nos dan la forma
estándar y yo no quiero pasar por
ejemplo a la forma a mi forma favorita a
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen es
decir vamos a escribirla aquí la famosa
pendiente ordenar el origen la forma
pendiente ordenado origen es y es igual
a mx + vez que pues esencialmente es
despejar ayer así que vamos a darle la
primera ecuación y vamos a despejar
alguien tengo 5 x menos de hoy es igual
a 15 a 15 positivo y después pues lo
primero que voy a hacer es restar menos
5x de ambos lados de la ecuación menos 5
x de este lado
aquí 5x de aquí menos 5x y estos dos se
van entonces solamente me queda que 22
james es igual a 15 menos 5x y ahora lo
que voy a hacer es dividir todo entre
menos 2 lo que quiero es despejar ayer
para estar en la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen así que todo esto
entre menos 2 - 2 menos dos se van
solamente me queda
james del lado izquierda de la ecuación
mientras que del lado derecho me queda
15 entre menos 2 pues esto es menos 7.5
y después menos entre menos me da más 5
entre dos es 2.5 así que a esto le voy a
sumar más 2.5 x si estamos bien si más
2.5 x y bueno si lo quiero acomodar esto
para que se vea mucho más clara la forma
pendiente ordenada de origen me queda
que james es igual a 2.5 x menos 7.5 y
aquí claramente ya se ve que no está
pendiente quieras de ordenar el origen
está de aquí ésta es la pendiente la
pendiente mientras que menos
- 7.5 todo esto de aquí es la hornada el
origen o la intersección con el eje de
las 10 la intersección con el eje las
guías y ya tengo el primer ejercicio de
la forma estándar a la forma pendiente
ordenada al origen así que vamos a ver
el siguiente el siguiente dice 3x massey
es igual a 25 y lo primero que voy a
hacer es pasar este 3x del otro lado de
la ecuación y me queda que 6 james es
igual a 25 menos 3x y ahora voy a
dividir todo en 36 y me queda que quien
es igual a 25 sobre 6 menos 3 sobre 6
pero menos 3 sobre 6 es lo mismo que un
medio menos un medio de equis y entonces
esto es lo mismo que ya es igual a menos
un medio de x más 25 sextos y otra vez
ya sabemos que la pendiente es el
coeficiente que hasta lado de la equis
esta es mi pendiente mientras que esta
es la intersección con el eje de las
1025 sextos es b y pues vamos a
finalizar con este último ejercicio 9 x
menos 9 james igual a 4 y en este
ejercicio quiero proceder de una manera
distinta que te parece
y lo primero que hago es dividir entre
menos 9 entre menos 9 porque voy a
despejar bien es exactamente lo mismo
que hacerlo de la manera cotidiana
solamente que quiero hacerlo un poco más
divertido y que te des cuenta que
podemos llegar de dos maneras distintas
al mismo resultado así que voy a dividir
todo entre 9 todo entre 9 todo entre 9
de hecho todo entre menos 9 me va a
servir más que tenga menos 9 porque lo
que voy a hacer es la aie positiva y
entonces si de una vez volvemos a la ye
positiva va a ser muy fácil despejar
allí en 9 entre menos 9 me da menos 1 -
1 x x menos x menos nueve menos 9 se va
a quedar más del otro lado me queda
menos 4 novenos es más déjame ponerlo
aquí menos 4 y no menos porque ahora lo
que voy a hacer es sumar x de ambos
lados de la ecuación y entonces esta x
va a pasar del otro lado y me va a
quedar con color amarillo voy a poner a
la x positiva para que se cancelen más x
+ x y entonces x menos x se van y
solamente me queda que james es igual a
x
cuatro novenos y otra vez ya que estamos
en la forma pendiente hornada al origen
porque la pendiente es el coeficiente
que está al lado de la equis que en este
caso es 1 mientras que en el origen o
ven a la intersección con el eje de las
10 es igual a menos 4 novenos y ya está